the next important area of skills that
you need to build our communication
skills of course communication is
extremely important as a consultant as a
consultant you're frequently in a
position to lead client meetings to sit
together also with senior people in the
client organization talk to them
convince them of your ideas
communication skills are surely
extremely important for that so in
Consulting another area where your
communication skills will be heavily
assessed is so good you are with
PowerPoint how good you are with
creating slight presentation slide
documents it is not only a cliche that
as a consultant you will produce lots of
slides for many types of projects a
slide deck is one of the key
deliverables that you will leave the
client with after you leave